so um the uh subject of this talk is
going to be about shiny which is a uh
python uh data science web application
framework and in particular kind of the
details of how shiny renders things
because um that is a big part of like
understanding that algorithm is a big uh
part of understanding why shiny is worth
your time and also how to use shiny to
best effect so the main thing that I
learned um as a data scientist is that
when you're building data science
applications you really need a
application framework with range what I
mean by range is something that can
handle very very small problems as well
as very very big ones and the reason um
for that is that data science projects
in particular usually um start small um
but end complicated so they start as a
simple dashboard or a model something to
explain a model but then as those things
become more useful and more used by your
organization um people add requirements
and they grow in scope right and if you
pick a framework that's limited that
handles the simple cases really well but
doesn't have the tools to build larger
more complicated apps in a performant
and kind of easy to understand way um
you're in for a lot of pain and I've
seen this a lot with people building
simple sort of Demos in one application
framework and then needing to just throw
the whole thing away and build it again
in JavaScript halfway through the
project those things can be really
really difficult and so the question I
encourage you to sort of ask when you're
thinking about this is both does your
framework solve the problems that you're
facing right now but also are they going
to solve tomorrow's problems are they
going to be able to handle the problems
that you that come up in the future and
understanding the way these Frameworks
work a little bit helps you kind of
anticipate whether they're going to be
able to do
that um so shiny is a new to python
framework it has a long history in our
community but uh there's a u it's the
idea is that it's a framework for
building fast extensible uh web
applications um a pure python
implementation was released about a year
ago and the core value proposition is
that shiny is easy enough for rapid
prototyping so you can build something
in a couple of hours or a day but it has
everything that you need to build a full
featured product so if your application
does grow and become something that you
your team or your company need to rely
on for a long period of time um we have
all of the tools that you need to build
and maintain a performant large
application so let's just take a look at
an example here um so this is a an
example um with three tabs so the first
one is a model training dashboard second
one's some monitoring and the last one
is data anotation and so this is kind of
shows a little bit the growth of a of a
data science web application so maybe I
build a little classification model and
I want to expose it to people to be able
to show them like how that model
performs on their particular account so
this may be something I would have a
sales rep have open when they're talking
to um you know FR and frit or whatever
company whatever fictitious company
they're selling to um and then I have
the second selector that changes the um
the metric plot that I'm I'm using you
can imagine this getting having more
options so the two things I kind of want
to point out about how shiny works here
what shiny is doing is the first one is
that when I change this um account plot
since or account selector since both of
these plots rely on that account
selector they both update um but when I
change this metric plot only this one
updates right so shiny is minimally
rendering component
based on what needs to change right so
this this training scores plot doesn't
depend on this metric selector so it's
not changing the second thing I want to
point out and this is I can't really
show this to you you just have to
believe me is that um these background
tabs uh are not rendering at all so
whatever is happening on these
background tabs until the user actually
clicks on it um these are not calculated
so these are calculated live when the
user is interacting with them so I could
have 100 or you know 100 tabs here
and there wouldn't really be a
performance imp implication of how fast
the model how fast this application
loads because the background tabs aren't
doing anything and so those are the kind
of that's the sort of performance or the
efficiency of Chinese uh framework that
it's able to do this it's able to create
these
applications so the question you might
ask is like okay well how would you do
this right like how how does this work
how would you sort of implement that
that and um one implementation if you're
familiar with gradio um this is how kind
of gradio would Implement something like
this um and there's two kind of features
of of gradio and I think a lot of other
python web application Frameworks the
first is that you have manual State
Management so I'm sort of instantiating
a state variable and manually like
populating that deciding when it gets
updated deciding when it gets changed
how it's
initiated um and the second is that
there's manual callback uh management so
I have um this selector called account
and I'm saying like when I this uh event
handler that says like when account
changes the selection do this stuff then
do this stuff then do this stuff and I
have another callback for when the
metric changes so do this do this do
this
this when you look at the shiny code
it's it's pretty different right so this
is the total amount of code that chin is
using to draw those two plots and when
you look at it you start of realize well
hang on there's no State Management here
and there are no call back functions
here right and that's that's a little
confusing because like how does chiny
know what to do if I'm not telling it
what to do another way of putting this
is to say we told shiny what to do we
told them how to draw this score
distribution plot how to draw this
metric plot how to select which plot to
pick um but we didn't tell shiny when to
do it right that's something that the
programmer is not responsible for and
that's a little weird because usually in
these Frameworks the programmer needs to
kind of be in the weeds you know doing
like nitpicky changes about callbacks
and
state um how do other friend Frameworks
work well so streamlet is a has a pretty
blunt but easy to understand execution
method which is just renders everything
all the time this is great because it
means that you can take a script and
turn it into a web
application um and uh without needing to
think too hard about it but as your
application grows of course rerunning
everything becomes an increasingly large
performance
problem um and then most of the other
ones Dash gradio Solara to some degree
um use event handling and what event
handling or event driven programming is
is just kind of what I showed you in
that code snippet which is you're
manually defining the behavior which
triggers a callback function so you the
programmer are responsible for that and
you the programmer have the opportunity
to mess that up right so you have to do
it is one of the problems with event
driven programming um it's can be fairly
easy to get wrong if you update state in
a the wrong order or your callbacks
functions fire um incorrectly or there's
some kind of race condition um things
like that and it can be pretty hard to
tell when you get it wrong so my
experience with with Avenger programming
is that when they fail um it fails by
showing the wrong answer in the app
rather than crashing or not showing
anything my favorite example of this is
slack uh periodically every you know
month or so I get this slack activity
notification that I cannot dismiss it
just stays there forever until somebody
fixes the bug and I have this suspicion
that deep in this slck kind of
notification world there's a mishandled
call back that's going wrong so better
way you might think of your application
as a directed graph right so graphs are
great because we know from the graph
structure exactly what needs to be
rendered to keep it up to date so in
this case if C changed we would know we
need to update e g and I but we wouldn't
need to update B because it doesn't have
a dependency on C right so this is a
really appealing way of doing these kind
of efficient re executions but it has
its own problem which is that you have
to kind of Define this graph structure
which can be just as hard as to finding
callbacks so shiny strategy is is pretty
special um what it does is it infers the
relationships between components uses
those relationships to build a
computation graph and then uses that
graph to minimally reexecute your
application and I would suggest that if
somebody kind of like me comes and says
like hey I'm doing some magic inference
to minimally render something with a
graph you know you should be a little
suspicious right you should say like
okay prove it to me show me how this
actually works so that I can trust
it and I think the two sort of key
things about this working is that for
this to work this inference needs to be
100 % accurate right so it's it's not
good enough if we get this right 90% of
the time because that's kind of worse
than doing nothing right it gives you
like terrible bugs that you have to
worry about and then for you this to be
useful to you you kind of have to
understand that it's working or how it's
working have to trust it right um so if
you come in too shiny with a the idea
that you need to manually Define all the
callbacks you know that maybe is going
to cause you more trouble then it'll
save so one question is how would we do
this and an answer that comes up a lot
is you could maybe do static code
analysis um so I could read this code
and say like okay I have this thing
called score distribution and it's
reading an input so I could draw a link
between those
two that doesn't work because shiny
actually supports Dynamic user
interfaces so for example um this is a
little application that lets you add
to-dos and you know complete these
to-dos and this is uh the state of this
application any given point depends on
previous user actions so it's not
actually in the code like there's
nowhere in the code that says there's
two list components there's a a recipe
for for adding one of those when you
click the button right so I can't really
do static code analysis with Dynamic
user interfaces and we really want
Dynamic user interfaces so that wouldn't
work so instead what shiny does is
something called runtime tracing what
runtime tracing is is basically we watch
what all the components ask for what
things they need to run their
calculations and we use those to keep
track of relationships and then those
relationships we can then use to build
our graph and Trigger our our perfect re
rendering um so let's just walk through
a little a little bit of code to kind of
walk through how this what I mean by ask
for what components ask for so the first
thing that happens is the user opens up
the application they request this plot
by it showing up so they requested this
plot because it's being viewed um that
has an ID that ID links back to a
rendering function um which has
triggered when the rendering function
runs it asks for some other inputs and
these can be either static like in this
case they could also be dynamically
generated and then we get the input
right so that's the sort of asking for
this component of the link of what shiny
is doing and you can kind of think of
this as a small graph by just an input
to an output I'm going to talk about
inputs as squares and outputs as
circles um so let's review this graph
again so we have this account slider
which is consumed by both of these plots
and then we have this metric slider
which is only consumed by one and when
chiny opens up it doesn't actually know
anything about the relationships between
these things the only thing it knows is
that there are four of them there's two
inputs and two outputs and it goes and
just tries to calculate the plot so it
calculates the metric plot first and
Metric plot needs is both the metric
selector and the account selector and we
got our little metric plot and the
distribution plot only needs the account
selector doesn't care about the metric
selector so since this is only asking
for this one we only draw that one line
and right there we have our dag we have
our reactive graph and we can use that
to do rendering so when the account
selector changes these it what it does
what's called invalidate which means
just say you need to recalculate you're
no longer up to date um it invalidates
two plots because it just follows those
lines down and says those two had a
dependency last time this ran and then
we forget everything uh forget all of
the dependencies attached to an
invalidated output and we go ahead and
calculate it again so metric plot
calculates then distribution and we're
back to our same graph if the metric
sector changes though the only thing
that is invalidated is the metric plot
and since um the distribution plot was
not invalidated it's all of its uh
Upstream dependencies were the same that
means we don't need to calculate it so
we just recalculate the metric plot and
we get the same
output
right um so that's kind of like a maybe
seems a little bit Overkill because this
graph ends up the same every single time
but these graphs can actually change
dynamically so for example I have this
case here I have a radio button which
allows me to select which slider is
active so this one the slider one is
active but slider two is not changing
anything if I change the radio button
now slider two is going to change it
and slider one is not going to do
anything um here's the code that is
generating that text so again it's a a
rendering function but it has this
conditional or it's if Choice One if the
choice is slider one do this one
otherwise do slider
two and when I when I start up again I
have shiny doesn't know the relationship
between these things just knows there
are these three inputs the buttons and
the two sliders and this text output so
when I call that when I try to calculate
the text output I'm going to go ask for
buttons and then get slide slider one
and if slider two changes um nothing is
going to happen right because what shiny
knows is that since you didn't ask for
slider two last time that means it
doesn't affect the calculation that you
came to there's got to be some sort of
early return or it's just not consumed
at all so I I can kind of ignore this um
input for for this purpose when slider
one changes the same thing happens it's
invalidated we go back get the buttons
button says go fetch slider one and then
we're back to our output if the buttons
change the out point to slider two um we
have a different case so in this case
since it's pointing to slider two um it
invalidates so recalculates text goes
and gets the buttons button says go
fetch slider two and then we have this
new graph where um slider two is active
and slider one is not active and this
again kind of leads to this implicit um
efficiency of the of the framework
because these types of changes are
attracted minimally right so you end up
with the accurate graph all the time and
that graph gives you more or less
perfect rendering of your up
application um so the great thing about
this approach is that this is actually
scales right so you can use very very um
simple um applications can run with
reactive reactivity but you can also
build complicated ones and importantly
every single shiny app from very small
ones to very very large ones uses the
exact same mental model of how these
applications work works for dynamic at
uis um that's what creates that kind of
laziness where background Tabs are not
calculated um and you know that if your
application grows you're not going to
suddenly need to like switch from using
like rerun everything to manual State
Management and streamlet or from using
stateless callbacks in dash to caching
data in a redus database to share them
between things right shiny like it's
just reactivity there's nothing else
that kind of happens it's it's able to
span that the full range of data science
problems um I just want to check the
questions here real quick uh so the
question is um is this like Jango and
flask um it's it's not really so jeno
and flask don't generate UI um they're
mostly like for the backend part of the
application and uh there's usually like
some other UI frontend usually
JavaScript on front of it so shiny does
both of them so this um this application
there's no JavaScript that was written
this is all done in Python there's a
python function that defines the cards
one that defines the plots you know
there's no it's just 100%
python okay so the um last thing want to
talk about is um reactive
calculations so uh what so far we've
been working with basically pretty
shallow graphs right like all of the
inputs are directly consumed by a
rendering function this is not that
exciting right like it's if you think of
that big graph that I showed you that
had a lot of nuance there were like
these intermediary nodes it was deep and
that depth is what leads to actual like
real efficiency gains um so we have a we
have a decorator called reactive calc um
which creates calculations whose results
can be used by other reactive calcs or
other rendering functions this basically
adds additional nodes adds depth to our
reactive
graph and this'll become more clear with
an example so here's an example where I
have this again is like this dashboard
growing so I have the training dashboard
and then the model say got put in
production and now I need to monitor it
right and I still have this um uh
account selector but what I want to do
is I want to populate this from a
database sample so I want to be able to
like select some date
and then take a sample between these
dates in particular I want this part to
happen in the database like I want this
to be a SQL query that that queries the
database for all the accounts and I want
this part up here to happen in memory
because I want this switch to be really
quick so what do I want so just to
specify the six things that I'm
demanding I'm a very demanding user so I
want to query the database to sample
between dates I want to then be able to
filter that sample by account in memory
and I want to share that data between
the two plotting functions so I don't
want to have two copies of the data
floating around I just want to use one
um now to get more difficult I want to
cach the results of one and two so when
um the account changes I don't want to
take a new sample I want to retrieve the
cached sample and I want to retrieve a
cached sample for each account filtered
with these two
plots and I want to invalidate that
cache only when the Upstream inputs
change so I want that to that cache to
go away whenever the dates or the sample
changes um but I I don't want to take
like a retrieve a old sample from cash
every time the sample changes I want to
take a new sample and lastly and
importantly for me I don't want to work
think or work very hard um I don't want
to like worry about it I just want shiny
to get this right all the time and this
is the things that I think shiny does
better than any other framework and
particular these last three like there's
often ways of accomplishing some some
set of these but the ones where you can
do the first five with most of these
other Frameworks usually involve a lot
of thinking and work at that's something
that I'm unwilling to
accept so reactive calculations are
defined with a reactive Cal decorator
and the idea is that it caches its value
so that it's cheap to call repeatedly
and adds a node to the reactive graph so
because it's in the reactive graph we
can use that to do cache management so
we can discard the cache value when the
Upstream parts of the graph changed and
we can notify the downstream things that
its value has
changed um so here's an example of of
this reactive calculation so you see I
have um reactive Cal decorators that are
just def decorating a python function
and then this is the render plot uh that
would plot one of those score plots um
so these can be stacked so here I have
this sample data function which is then
being called by uh filtered data so this
is basically like referring to that
function and then um that filter data is
called by the plotting function
there um so I'm going to represent these
um reactive calculations with these
little hexagons so again when shiny
opens to First launch it doesn't know
anything about this application it just
knows there's two plots three inputs and
two reactive
calculations and so the first thing it
does is it goes and generates tries to
generate the model score plot um that
model scores needs the filter data frame
so it says okay I got to go get the
account input and the sampled reactive
calculation and then when it tries to
figure out what the sampled reactive
calculation is it says oh I've got to go
get this dates and sample
size right so this is kind of the
process of this scaling in complexity
right we've added some layers to it you
could imagine this getting much larger
if we needed to but it would still
generate the correct graph and when I do
try to calculate the API response I just
go and get the cached value filtered
right this hasn't change none of its
Upstream nothing Upstream of this has
changed so I can just retrieve the cache
value and know that it's correct that
means that these two plots are going to
always share the same data and they're
never going to do more calculations than
they need to they're never going to take
that filter twice they're never going to
take that sample
twice
um if the account changes um the
filtered reactive calculation is
invalidated so it says okay filtered
invalidated forget your dependencies and
also tell your Downstream dependencies
that they're invalidated right because
if you're wrong then anything that
depended on you is wrong and so then the
two plots get invalidated as well and we
do the same thing we calculate the model
scores um and we go get the account but
this time we just take the cached value
of sample because again the date and the
sample size hasn't changed so we can
retrieve the cache and AP response does
the same thing that it always does which
is just retrieve the cached
value when the sample size changes
though um everything is invalidated this
is kind of like a primary node so
everything Downstream of it going to
change going to invalidate and it turns
out that's all of the relationships so
then we're back to our starting place of
recalculating the whole score so model
scores gets filtered gets account gets
sample gets these two other inputs and
then the API response
calculates um are there any questions
about that or about anything that I've
kind of covered so
far okay um then very quickly I'm going
to go through uh effects so this is the
kind of like f another stage of this
getting more complicated which like
maybe I'm not satisfied with my model
performance so I want to like do some
annotation right so I want to just like
check that this is you know Electronics
or not electronics and have this right
back to a database and so the this this
interaction is really hard to think
about with the tools that we've used so
far because it's I'm not really asking
for the value I'm asking to modify the
state of a v of a data frame and so
these would be called um effects so
reactivity I think it's a great default
for these applications but not
everything fits it right sometimes you
do actually want to um specify a side
effect or specify that when something
happens right so you know you want to
batch inputs together trigger a side
effect and event driven programming it's
not like all bad it's just I think it
it's it's complicated when you use it as
your only
tool um so what we want is we want this
annotation to happen when the user does
something so I want to specify when um
and uh I don't want it to happen to
react automatically to those
inputs um so this is the code that does
that so we have these decorators
reactive effect and reactive event so
reactive effect basically marks it as an
effect which means that there's no
return value that needs to get plugged
into a reactive graph it just kind of
happens and then this always almost
always his with a reactive event which
basically just specifies when this
particular input changes fire the the
function um so this is really identical
to like an onchange um event listener in
in another framework and then we have
the content which actually does The
annotation um so reactive event can also
be paired with a reactive Cal or
rendering function if you want those to
be you want override reactivity in those
cases and the way I think about this is
it kind of like adds react Ren sprinkles
or chocolate chips to a reactive cookie
right so you want that to be like
something that it's not your first tool
that you go to mostly you want to use
these reactive um calculations because
they'll tend to be more efficient and
easier to do but when you do need to
kind of trigger a side effect or
something um that's a good way of doing
it um the overall rule of when to pick
one or the other is about side effects
and values um so reactive effect is for
side effects that's why it has effect in
the name this is like updating a
database deploying a model writing a CSV
something that is like affecting the
world outside of your application um and
reactive calc or rendering functions is
for values so if I'm running a
calculation or fetching data from a
database or filtering a data frame um
I'm doing something where I'm consuming
the value within the
application um lastly uh we have a lot
of other patterns that as you kind of
think about this and you think like aha
that's a way that like dags are not
going to work like if you have a cycle
in your graph you know we actually have
a lot of functions that handle most of
those cases if you find one that we
don't handle we'd love to hear about it
um so some other things you should just
be aware of is reactive isolate to
prevent Cycles in the graph um you can
include data like a database or a flat
file with reactive Pole or reactive file
reader um you could have parts of your
graph rerender on a schedule with
invalidate later so that's basically
having a something where it's IR valid
but then just keep a timer for 5 seconds
and then invalidate and invalidate all
of your Downstream
dependencies and you can store things in
variables with reactive value
um so the summary just a takeaway is
shiny creates very performant apps with
very little work um I think it's Al
algorithm is great it's elegant but it's
not magic um you can actually understand
and have an intuition about how this
algorithm works and your framework
should uh be able to handle what your
users want right so you should be able
to have your framework grow with your
the things that your users want to do
today but also with what they want to do
tomorrow and it's a real shame to end up
with a framework that limits you in
terms of how you're able to respond to
those
requests and that's that's all I've got
here uh so I have a couple minutes for
questions if there's anything but
otherwise um thank you very much for
your attention